hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I am Jerry
feel like a 90s hip-hop rapper yeah okay
yo what's up machi mock [__] homo
very that's how we sounded very popular
song we're gonna check out from uh you
know a movie the green inferno red bang
clip called punishment oh oh god no this
is from Eli Ruth it's rated R for a
never even heard that word aberrant vile
aberrant violence every box set is
really despicable really like you know
mean violence and torture grisly
disturbing images brief graphic nudity
what a bunch of [__] Google is
violence but barely any tits and [__]
sexual content language some drug use it
pretty early night as if it ain't drugs
and [__] you don't just fill it with
vine you I you're letting me down you're
letting me down Eli the movie with Keanu
Reeves look better Mel recent look I'm
so nervous about to see
killing a black guy
Oh
feel like that scene is longer in the
movie yeah no [__] because that actual
or or maybe is longer on an unrated cut
of this movie because like that that
gouge was a little like oddly edited it
was a little Ollie attitude still
freaked me out cuz I thought I was gonna
get significantly worse yeah well they
built the Dredd really nicely poor guy
he was like huh
thank you oh thank you yeah then you got
his eye gouge out
yeah man cannibal movies have that sort
of very hyper naturalistic thing that's
always very like bleak and upsetting
I gotta say it looks shot beautifully
like yeah watch it I'm like there's some
cool cinematography actually and the OL
environment of it all as its you're
right yeah it's gonna be a [__] movie
oh yeah and it's you know gonna feel
very isolated cannibal movies have a
real knack for making you feel very
small yeah alone so is Veronica is a
very big rock for making me feel small
now and then I hand up a loan I don't
know it's it's it's heavy shouldn't have
bought her that purple thing I got a
direction I bought her that that's all
she uses now man she's all she uses now
man she doesn't even say my name she
says too right
she says she moons his guy named Greg
Greg Proops the comedy guy no no I know
this really good-looking [__]
named Greg Alba oh yeah I've heard his
name I've always said if there was one
guy [__] Ryan Gosling the fear and
suspension is really felt like the
terror and some people's in like the
characters eyes looks like authentic
it's just this looks like they're really
scared of what's going on it doesn't
yeah I mean granted we didn't get to see
much of the acting but it didn't feel as
Eli Roth over the top like I'm used to
it might be at the beginning might be
but yeah it's the clip barely showed it
certainly does encapsulate that feeling
of being lost and in way over your head
you can happened that's that's what
these movies thrive on you know alright
Eli Roth I'm looking for both your
movies this year thanks but like I'm
sure a horrible fate is gonna be full
everyone at these Carrie I
hope so they're all gonna be I just
don't want them one like do anything to
a woman's tits or vagina a might that's
what I don't like like some people like
movies really would cut off their
nipples a oh he'll it's like it's the
kind of things what are they going to do
because to them this is probably some
kind of ritual
there's something else in cannibal
movies where it's like it's not even
malicious it's not like a slasher movie
words like all that guy he's evil you
wanna kill you it's like you're just
trespassing in their place yeah you're
just a part of their normal ritual
usually they always you know draw that
gap it's like oh we don't know what
they're saying we don't know their
culture at all and so that makes it even
more mysterious can't communicate or get
through them all yeah so it's it's a
special kind of isolation yeah I really
want to put myself in this world anyway
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects you
can check out reasons to Gerry on this
channel and Dan gasps Stubbs hosted by
jer-bear and you could follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope because if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
for things such as what up box what box
plus I'm gonna be very straightforward
with you guys I already got product
placement from them fantastic company
you know if you guys buy more worn-out
boxes that would be great because you
get a share in the joy of having cool
chains like this cool shirts like this
yeah yeah you get a bunch of fun cool
toys and stuff more importantly if you
guys buy a 1up box for either myself or
Tyrone Magnus you can help us make more
money we need your money I mean it would
increase production value I know what
you're saying this is exactly why he's a
little easier yeah exactly why I don't
like youtubers when they get a little
bigger because is then sold out the
money it's all about the money but I'm
trying to tell you right now I could use
the extra can use money I just found out
from Jerry that they're going to just
like the government is gonna stay away
from states that have already legalized
marijuana right or medical marijuana
well I read in the paper yeah yeah
so Michael they're not gonna go raid
those places there's more
opportunity for more weed out here so if
you guys help me buy this green I could
get more green meaning more
entertainment for you guys it's an
investment back into the channel are
there are you sure this is the kind of
Association they want you to plug yeah
what up box when you run out of jokes to
make about other random products you
just go to the real thing